Any update on the Jimmy...situation?
Handled, my liege
He is in good spirits and should
be returning to practice today
Oh...so he no longer wants to be traded?
Um...well...uh...we're working...ya know...
Who wants to DIE today???
Ah, that must be him now
KAT, do something!
Don’t worry. He can’t do shit against me.
I hope that means you worked on your defense
I’ll take those two G Realm peasants,
the muffin maker’s boy
and that there mangy goat.
When they mop whatever’s left of you lily-livered cowards off the court,
they’ll wish they traded me sooner!
He doesn’t seem very happy
Oh, that's just Jimmy
Gotta love the intensity he brings...even to practice
Hallelujah, Wiggins!
Should I send your bones to your brother???
No! Please, no!
You f--king need me!
Ah!!!
Thibby, I just don’t have the stomach for this
This is the best practice all year
Jimmy! Here! The Muffin Boy! I’m open!
He’s motivating them
We yield! We yield! Stop! Stop it, please!
Aw, seems I’ve found the Towns Crier
Hahaha!!!
He’s slaughtering my little Timberpups
Oh, this was supposed to be our year!
Hey you, get me a f--king salad! Balsamic dressing
Actually, no dressing. I’ll use this.
-Oh, dear god
-You just got served muffins and milk!
As we said at House Bulls,
if you’re not mortally wounded, you can still play 48 minutes.
Oh my goodness, is that Andrew’s heart?
Nay. That’s too big.
Pardon me, uh, have you seen my heart?
Not now, Andrew!
Thomas, it might be time to admit this situation is untenable
What? It’s tenable. It's very tenable.
It’s one of the most tenable situations I have ever...
tended over
Curse these forsaken Twin Cities!
TRADE ME!
Remember, last season we were
a 3 seed before he got hurt
Curse this wretched house!
TRADE ME!
I swear this will all work out just fine if we’re just patient—
And f--k you, Lord Thibodeau!
Your rotations are shit!
Well, I do suppose I like Robert Covington’s hustle
Oh, how exciting is this, Lord Commander?
Jimmy can take us over the top! He could change everything with his intensity!
Oh, here he comes now!
Is that a mini-carriage?
He sure does have a lot of baggage
Um...I’d like to be traded, please
Hello, city of Brotherly Love!!!
Shall we complete this process now?
Jimmy! Here! The Muffin Boy! I’m open!
Yes! I just scored a three-pointer!
That feels better than a blueberry muffin on a Sunday morning with some milk!
Haha! How do you like me muffins now?
You f--king need me!
Jimmy! Nice! You just turned him into a muffin!
Take that!
Blueberry muffins! And corn muffins! And chocolate chip muffins!
Haha! I just put a muffin on his head!
Hah! I know how to make muffins just like my dad!
Good people of Youtube!
Please pledge your fealty to the Kingdom of Balleros
and click "SUBSCRIBE"
It shows support for the show,
and allows us to send you ravens when new episodes come out
I want more episodes about Kobe!
Yeah!